hier soir dans le pas de calais des
pompiers ont dû intervenir pour porter
secours à un enfant de 18 mois selon
france bleu nord l'enfant a été
gravement blessé au visage et aux bras
et transportée d'urgence au chr de lille
l'auteur de ces morsures un chien nous
américains une espèce non reconnue en
france un drame qui rappelle une autre
affaire qui avait déjà défrayé la
chronique le chien était placée dans un
endroit clos mais certains appellent
appliquée l'animal alors fallait-il
l'euthanasier
incroyable un cette affaire gilles
verdez je comprends vous dit non non on
n'a pas le droit de vie ou de mort sur
les animaux
qui sont responsables ce sont ceux qui
importent sans autorisation ces chiens
qui ont des gènes du loup parfois 80 %
des animaux sauvages donc non il ne faut
pas ça il ne faut pas l'euthanasier il
est dans un endroit clos il faut
l'isoler on n'a pas le droit de le tuer
géraldine s'il te plaît
chez
tourne toi vers lui franchement moi je
n'ai toujours en fait un enfant avant un
animal et en chine en particulier
et là force est de constater que c'est
un chien prédateurs chiens dangereux ben
oui dans ce cas là moi je suis pour
l'euthanasie est dangereux donc on va
laisser dans un enclos et savez combien
ça va coûter qu'il a payé comment ça va
se passer donc non concrètement ce chien
ce chien ce prédateur n'a rien à faire
en france et moi j'en veux pas et alors
voilà je pense qu'aujourd'hui la victime
c'est la fillette et je trouve qu'on a
là on en a assez pardon ce chien tu veux
quoi quil tu veux qu'il aille faire un
nom mais j'ai jamais la raison il fait
quoi il fait quoi on le met dans un
enclos là on le confie à des gens
compétents c'est ça le drame c'est cher
temps et maintenant on fait quoi si mort
jeu quand je le laisse dans un enclos où
il sera seul et ce sont des gens
compétents qui sont c'est nul ça sert à
rien je suis petite fille tu ferais quoi
après une émission pour pleurer pour un
petite fille à noyen dans un bassin
d'emploi mais je trouve ça et frigide
d'udine un peu parfois tu dis des choses
qui n'ont pas de sens un animal un chien
qui mord qui mord malheureusement c'est
la règle on doit le supprimer parce qu'
un jour il y aura un accent encore plus
grave et moi j'ai pas envie qu'un jour
mon fils ou ma fille soit bouffer tué
par un seul et jeumont et c'est terrible
j'adore les chiens gérer ça mais bon
finalement ça n'a pas de sens on y
apprend que quand il ya eu une aventure
à quoi une belle émission pour qu'on
peut arrêter la dame ben voila moi même
ma fille a été bouffé par un chien j'ai
trop tard après c'est aux voix dire tout
de suite et dans leur même une fillette
de 18 mois 1 c'est terrible c'est
horrible c'est sympa ça pas de sens et
moi j'ai vivement mes enfants aux
charges désolé je vois pas tant que toi
qui saurait fait absolument pas mais moi
je suis moi je veux pas me substituer la
loi mais franchement je vous dis très
honnêtement j'adore les animaux j'ai des
chiens sur moi aussi j'adore pierre il
ya même pas de en fait tu sais quoi zing
ya même pas débat and animals qui s'en
est pris à un homme ou un enfant peu
importe ne peut plus rester sur terre
c'est la règle de base parce qu'un jour
il y aura un accès de quelques rois de l
arrêt des mois et dont je ne remets pas
se faire j'ai envie de protéger mes
enfants et les gens qui sont aucun chien
qui mord on va le tuer mais absolument
elle baoulé ses rivales et des lyrics
ici je suis désolé alors c'est simple je
pense et je le mange à tuer moi je suis
un chèque qui a goûté le sang doit être
supprimée point barre point barre
regarde même temps
la junte et radicale ou un mois j'ai moi
j'ai eu des accidents gilles j'ai dit
mme pitt cousine qualité qui a perdu la
moitié du visage et aux yeux de la gorge
avec le son club comme ça on voit sa
trachée tu fais quoi un
ba1 à pareil pour pour pour respirer
alors on fait quoi après on va pleurer
encore mais je m'en fous du dieu du
chien c'est bouffe quelqu'un il meurt je
suis désolé c'est comme ça alors ses
fruits c'est un vrai pas mais oui c'est
le chien de la famille comme on dit la
fillette c'est une horreur douadi une
horreur je suis désolé j'adore les
animaux mais quand un animal qui s'en
est pris à l'homme qui a vraiment mordu
jusqu'au sang il n'ya pas d'autre choix
est-ce que vous avez vous avez moi
j'imagine qu'on a ramassé l'ajout d'un
petite cousine sur la table avec le club
local a l'air et ça va les arrêter à
quelques centimètres de la de la
jugulaire on peut pas prendre de risques
alors c'est terrible évidemment que je
vous dis une chose de tout temps été
dans les campings notamment quand il y
avait un accident quand les vaccins avec
un animal et avec un chien l'animal a
été abattu instantanément voilà dans les
campagnes où les chiens sont joints une
vraie place et ils sont extrêmement
importants quand il ya un accident on
prend pas de risques parce que on va
attendre quoique il ya un mort et un
drame c'est ça le problème est un chien
qui a mordu va recommencer et souvent
les chiens qui attaque ont montré des
signes avant-coureurs souvent ils ont eu
un comportement qui parce qu'il a
évidemment et delilah a raison et toi
aussi vous allez dire il faut éduquer
les blés les propriétaires nay mais bon
l'homme est normal pas de sarrians barda
ça on n'est pas là valérie benaïm six
ippons
envie de plus je vous respecte pas
la loi un chien chien qui attaque et un
du nombre à 24 et une arme par
destination sans que c'est extrêmement
dangereux et malheureusement il n'y a
pas d'autre choix et surtout on peut pas
prendre de risque pour un pour un enfant
et comme l'a dit très justement
géraldine j'aurai toujours j'aurai
toujours préféré un enfant est un être
humain enchère je suis désolé alors
guillaume on sait que t'as pas du tout
le même discours non je suis pas du tout
d'accord et berlin moi j'en ai marre
qu'on considère les chiens comme des
sous-espèces voir des objets et à la
poubelle et donc qu'on tue dès qu'il ya
un problème les chiens c'est des êtres
vivants qui sont dotés d'une sensibilité
qui ont le droit de vivre il existe
effectivement d'autres manières de les
mettre hors d'état de nuire que de les
tuer immédiatement et bizarrement on
fait passer avec les humains pourquoi
alors ce moment là un humain qui grâce à
notre main faut que tu aies
immédiatement moi je mets
la raison et pourquoi et pourquoi tiens
c'est un être des bêtes d'un sentiment
d'une sensibilité voilà et quand on
adopte un chien c'est pour l'aimer et
s'en occupe et quoi qu'il arrive pas
pour le tuer détient un problème je suis
désolé mais je suis le prochain d'autant
plus cher il faut tjrs un moment qui
seront les poteries
banon dis pas que c'est bien le chien le
pauvre chien le push yalaoui le prochain
il va se faire tuer il ne peut rien
c'est un choc à
l'arrivée alors il faut c'est un chien
qui n'a pas le droit d'être détenu les
fautifs déjà cédé propriétaire ait pas
de charge de 3 a dit que là c'est tout
non mais géraldine il c'est intéressant
ce que tu dis pas mais à aucun moment tu
parles de la fillette en fait c'est ça
on parle du chien le débat c'est sur le
champ d'un parent de la victime
c'est la fillette mais juste d'accord
mais ça c'est le chien oui bon ben c'est
à dire qu'ils sont donc tuer tous les
agresseurs en l'occurrence benjamin tu
as très bien expliqué à l'époque dans
les campagnes quand les chiens sont
comme ça des prédateurs aussi dangereux
et qu'ils ont vraiment abattu lâché h et
l'ajout de 18 mois alors on va faire
qu'on va lui donner des croquettes ont
baissé de coin mais c'est pas ça le
problème et récidive le problème c'est
que vous considérez les chiens comme des
seuls clubs les riches demeures et
tabous relève quand c'est les jeunes
venez donc le même discours à guillaume
il ya une question de mon clément guérin
qui nous dit imaginons vous êtes dans un
incendie il ya votre chien et un bébé
que vous ne connaissez pas il faut
sauver une personne en cour immédiat
chez le chien
été sauvé votre chien
mais attendez c'est pas fait je dis pas
que je préfère les chiens ou des traits
de dire non britannique prend mon chien
non mais où les méchants c'est comme les
enfants moi donc vous me posez la
question je tiens oui j'en ai en fait
j'en ai marre qu'on considérait ce
dernier considère les chiens comme une
sous-espèce ans sont des êtres vivants
mais là sont difficiles à trouver comme
des choses et spatial aient choisi un
chien plutôt qu'un bébé de l'asie match
c'est pas l'un ou l'autre
cela vient mon chien le souvenir d'une
arme on peut pas la question le jeu même
si la question est un peu caricatural ta
réponse est hallucinante en direct dans
une émission le choisit un chien plutôt
qu'à bébé que je ne connais pas ce que
tu viennes six réponses moi j'aime les
chiens j'ai pas toi je n'ai pas menti
j'en ai marre qu'on les considère comme
rien et qu'on les tuent dès qu'un
problème ce sont des êtres qui
ressentent qu'ils aiment qui souffrent
et c'est dégueulasse de tuer un chien
des calmants d'un problème c'était par
match et matthieu chalmé mois toujours
des jarrets distinguer deux choses que
pas pardon mais on parle pas de
n'importe quel chien mais encore une
fois quand on parle de chiens dangereux
comment la date la plus d'un chien chien
loup voilà chez le maire une espèce qui
n'est pas reconnu comme jean estime par
la société centrale canine exactement du
genre parle d'un chien entre guillemets
illégal c'est pas quel chien
effectivement donc ce genre de chien là
où les chiens dangereux comme on l'a vu
je connais plus la race de ce que
c'était alors j'adore les voilà
rottweiler tout ça ces chiens a effectué
également les a mérités de
ces signes ne sont pas parce quand ils
sont pas passés à l'action que tous
n'ont pas mordu ont fait rien mais
effectivement une fois qu'ils ont mordu
il ya même plus de débats avaient déjà
ils sont illégaux ils sont dangereux ils
ont mordu donc ils ont prouvé qu'ils
étaient dangereux là on les supprime
directement et supprime donc séduire les
séances et on les met dans une poubelle
et on est là non les euthanasies c'est
ce que ça s'appelle comme ça un chien
dangereux illégale et qui de surcroît à
mort d'une fillette de 18 ans paraît pas
effectivement on le supprime je ne sais
pas quoi de tenir d'autres et des gens
dont c'est le métier ça s'appelle les
éducateurs canins bon le métier c'est
justement de rappeler les faits rares
enquêtes alors je pense que t'en penses
assis par terre il
va pas si morte jeudi qu'il faut arrêter
de traiter ces animaux comme rien ce
n'est les priorités ce pardon je te dis
je t'adore mais là tu es plus crible
dans le débat tu viens de dire pourquoi
robert bunsen et répondent à leurs
demandes et mike fatima qui vient de
dire moi c'est de choisir entre un bébé
alors est un chien je la vois la chose
comment je peux me poser la question
sans foi je devrais pas levé 100 fois la
même chose d'accord mais c'est à dire
que demain quand tu seras sensé et
raisonnée tu reviendras tu diras ce sont
surtout des pas pardon pour ce que j'ai
dis sans revanche été une erreur je
porte mes excuses et ses serres dont à
une question débile voilà j'y réponds
mais c'est parti pour clément
mais c'est pas l'un ou l'autre oui mais
c'est un signe si c'est une mise en en
tout cas je ne sais pas me retrouver le
chien en disant c'est un seul club je
m'en fous qui meurent voilà ce que tu as
fait ce chien alors guillaume par
exemple ben pourquoi illégal il est non
domestiques tuent le prendrais dans son
appartement mais s'il est légal non mais
c'est pas en fait c'est pas ça la
question est un chien parce qu'il est
illégal a le droit de vivre
j'adore mais là tu fais clairement une
unique arche isation des rask et or y
pensez vous qu'il a fait mais non est en
train bébé est un chien je choisis le
chien ça veut dire clairement que tu dis
que le chien à haguenau incitant au
sirop d'érable dans le débat que celle
du bbc vous tandis que l'être humain est
plus important que le chien malade il
est où les toutes les drisses métro d'un
bandeau pour toi un être humain est
aussi important qu'un chien sur place
après le séisme en fait de faire venir
un chien entre les espèces et l'on dit
qu'en fait les chiens sait rien et les
êtres humains fois je suis d'accord
l'attendait ni l'eau ni je suis d'accord
à guillaume sur un point si on me
demande de choisir autrichien et
guillaume salle et daiwa giro sur me
demande de choisir entre un chien
guillaume je choisirais le chien oui
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
zinio vient de dire que un être humain
est aussi important qu'un chien ou chat
ou de chien ont là mon chien c'est vrai
que ces matchs en direct
finir chez les animaux c'est à dire que
tu va considérer que le chien est plus
important par exemple que la chenille
rwe peut-être que le moustique en a rien
à [ __ ] et tu décroches c'est pas dit
ça j'ai même si que c'était foutu
positionne gilles dans tout ça
tous les gens qui ont des chiens savent
qu'on a un rapport très particulier que
ces chiens que c'était extrêmement
sensible on aime taper sur ceux qui nous
rejoignent à 20h44 une fillette de 18
mois mordu au visage par un chien
fallait-il euthanasier le chien c'est la
question qu'on se pose et guillaume
vient de dire un truc regardez-vous
benjamin castaldi notamment il a dit que
voilà s'il y avait un jour un problème
il sauverait plus sain il a il ya son
chien et un bébé qui ne connaît pas le
chien benjamin pas grâce au twitter ce
soir
[Rires]
franchement tu au discours je trouve
aberrant il trouve aberrant effective
n'a pas d'enfants d'aller chez un
peut-être pour ça mais mais mais je
comprends pas comment tu peux dire une
chose aussi aussi bête en fait parce que
un animal qui s'attaque à un être humain
même si effectivement les n'est pas
responsable l'animal qu'elle est la
seule solution face à un drame pareil
pourquoi devait être une solution a donc
faire quoi tu vas prendre le chien tu la
mets dans un enclos tu vas t'en occupes
et u17 le rééduquer on sait très bien
qu'un chien qui a mordu mais est que
très peu rééducable cancéreuses et dansé
pour certaines races on connaît verra ce
qu'ils sont les chiens dangereux de base
a eu ce qui en fait que c'est un chien
tu alors qu'il y arrive il ya risque
d'accident jusqu'au info pour info la
fille est encore à l'hôpital y aura des
cicatrices a dit oui
quel chien je dis pas que c'est pas
grave mais arrêter en fait juste la
solution ce n'est pas tuer ou rien alors
c'est pas leurs émissions et bat de
l'ailé mais dont le risque qu'ils
recommencent tu comprends ça oui un seul
arrêt pour ça que c'est un sujet très
sensible pour une belle fin de course
comporte
en fait le premier chien que j'ai eu un
jour quand j'avais 12 ans on a fait un
repas de famille on a invité nos voisins
et ses voisins l'avaient un petit de 1
an et le petit voulait pas manger il a
reçu un petit pain au chocolat et au
final mon chien voulu prendre le petit
pain au chocolat sauf qu'il est allé
trop vite faisait huit ans que tu
mangeais plus de géant à l'époque
et du
centre quand on a commencé à hurler
enfin bon bref le chien avait mordu le
petit du coup on a dû aller aux urgences
le petit ensemble partout on voyait même
pas si les eut été touché ou pas c'était
vraiment un truc d'horreur est donc le
premier truc que mon père a voulu faire
il a voulu effectivement à la campagne
chercher le fusil pour tuer le chien un
bon bilan est donc ce qu'on a fait en
fait avec mon grand père c'est qu'on a
de suite repris le chien on allait le
cacher et moi j'ai eu la peur de ma vie
bien sûr pour ce petit parce que chez
moi il ya plein de sang partout dans la
cuisine mais j'ai aussi surtout eu peur
pour mon chien est en fait ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce jeune
homme bas il a 18 ans effectivement il
encore une cicatrice sur le front mais
il n'a jamais voulu à mon chien et puis
au final voilà mon cher un contrôle à la
vie maintenant 18 ans pour savoir si
elle en valois des cicatrices à vire à
vire et ce jeune là aussi les cicatrices
et je veux dire mais bon maintenant
c'est hyper en tout cas c'est hyper
délicat mais mais en tout cas ça peut se
régler effectivement par l'éducation et
par
le mal est fait le mal est fait le mal
est fait gilles moi je défends guillaume
sur le côté du choix mais sur le côté
vous pouvez pas dire que l'être humain
est supérieur aux chiens on est tous
pour l'égalité des espèces ou et pas
dire ça et vous n'avez pas le droit vous
n'avez pas le droit de décider qui que
vous soyez content eu un chien parce
qu'il est responsable d'une morsure on
n'a pas le droit sinon à ce moment là on
va tuer combien de chiens ont vaqué
combien d'animaux on n'a pas le droit
les animaux il faut les respecter enfin
il ya des lois dans sa maltraitance
animale
il faut dire quand même sur un plateau
de télé qu'on a beau aimer tous les
animaux mais de l'être humain sera
toujours au dessus les autres animaux et
si je dois choisir entre un cheval et un
être humain choisirait êtres humains
entre chiètres humain l'être humain on
trouve que tu vas un moustique est un
être humain un être humain l'être humain
est tout voulu malgré tout l'amour qu'on
a pour les animaux sinon ça devient
aberrant ce train de dire je n'avais pas
le droit de tuer un chien on n'est pas
loin des six déjà eu droit de 2,2
mais alors il y peut rien il est pas
dans le bon environnement passer
n'importe quoi vision qui n'est pas dans
le temps on adore les animaux vous dites
faut supprimer un chien comment tu peux
dire ça dans la même phrase un chien
c'est pas un objet déjà c'est un être
vivant donc respecter les déjà arrêté
diront dessus on supprime pas un géant
vale du quai tu vas le rééduquer et pas
moi il ya deux ans on sait le mieux
qu'en donnant dans ces métiers vont les
accueillir
la vraie question qui fait énormément
parler là si vous mangez à 20h48 c'est
la déclaration vidéo wii qui dit un an
soit là si je dois sauver un chien bo le
chien ou un bébé que je sors mon cher
voilà alors guillaume il est des fous
dos et chiens comme elle tous d'ailleurs
voilà c'est vrai qu'il est voilà il a
cité une sociabilité un particulier et
qui nous touche tous moi mon chien voilà
c'est vrai aussi que voilà j'en suis fou
n'a l'a d'ailleurs je l'embrassé qu'il
nous regarde
son 400 mètres carrés
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là des jeunes je l'embrasserai quel
invité ses potes ce soir non mais c'est
vrai et c'est rick voilà il ya des gens
qui sont choqués car ça il y en a qui
sont d'accord à guillaume reymond prime
ils sont dix ans moi je mets ce jour je
vais mettre ma fille est de bien sûr au
dessus at war et ainsi le chien il a
mordu une fois il va rarement bien sûr
une fois non mais c'est super sérieux
mais ça je me suis endormi
alors c'est du tout l'appareil mais si
si la mort d'une fois il est dangereux
c'est un chèque est dangereux après
tu peux prendre du temps comme adige et
l'allemagne leurs questions réservations
sur la question vient de poser ses
valises
on peut pas entendre ça un chien plus
important qu'un bébé c'est là dessus
qu'on l'ait maintenant
qu'un bébé moi je te le dis mais je vais
même plus loin non c'est
moi je vais plus en parler en même temps
un chien et tue quelqu'un voulait tuer
le chien mais quand un humain tué un
autre humain voulait pas tuer même plus
loin avenue mceachran humain eh ben on a
4 mai
[Applaudissements]
il a tué délibérément quatre personnes
même après cela devient n'importe
qui n'importe quoi ils veulent vraiment
mais on peut pas qu'on peut pas là on va
se faire dans le domaine on ne peut pas
là la hongrie sont fait qu'est ce qu'on
fait et ba oui je sais vous êtes
aujourd'hui c'est non mais la peine de
mort bah quoi il a toujours dit qu'il
était dg d'iliad et qu'à rendre ici pas
décaler leur
écot à la connerie sur connerie l'agencé
pap la matière n'ont pas encore marqué
moi moi je te le dis le chien pour moi
il a mordu une fois je veux pas tirer
mort d'une deuxième fois je suis du même
avis que benjamin je veux pas que ça
arrive une deuxième fois donc il faut
l'euthanasier je réponds à la question
voilà c'est tout même à la question est
ce qu'un bébé est plus important qu'un
chien oui un bébé est plus important
qu'un chien mais je suis outré de vous
voir quand et à quel point vous les
flinguer les animaux oui mais quand des
ordures lagarde un humain lui vient des
ordures d'humains et au par contre vous
les gens sur terre c'est ça qui est un
peu bizarre sans pitié avec les animaux
vous êtes beaucoup trop indulgent avec
les humains il ya des êtres humains un
violent feu violent qui agressent et qui
tuent volontairement le chien il ne le
fait pas volontairement ça se trouve il
est dans un mauvais environnement il a
été mal éduqué mais qu'il a été battu
lui tire déjà un site déjà je sais
pourquoi une victime parce qu'il est
dans un environnement qui ne doit pas
être le sien il est détenu de manière
illégale au confiance à oui c'est une
victime je suis sûr que quand il fait ça
il ne sait pas qui va agresser blessés
chez direction primaire animal
instinctive et vous êtes beaucoup plus
indulgent avec des humains qui sont des
départs dont mes démerdes leur dire
violent qui tue volontairement quelqu'un
pauvre chien dès qu'il a le malheur de
mordre mais ben internet enfin il faut
le but est de l'asie gc - is all access
que tu as tout dit justement il sait
même pas qu'il le fait à 8 ce qui
différencie un animal de l'être humain
la raison est là confiants 2 et la paix
a donc effectivement
ils vont trouver du mal c'est un animal
toilettes numéro deux tabourets
lendemain ça ne vous reste que douch ait
de raison l'heure n'est pas
allé en avril après il ya des gens qui
vont venir c'est encore pire accident
sur le premier secteur pas sur un débat
qui avait d'abord la
peine de mort daniel on va passer l'air
si je vous entends tout c'est en fait il
faut il faudrait créer une prison pour
chien c'est à dire que si on les tue pas
on l'aimé où on l'aimé en prison parce
qu'ils ont mais une étoile
recommenceront je suis d'accord avec
tous ceux qui ont dit ça et est ce qui
me fait peur c'est qu'on ait dit cela
autour de la table il y en a déjà deux
qui pensent la même chose parce que tu
avais bien faire sauter ces jeunes j'ai
bien écouté ce que tu es ma qualité à
ton histoire et ai été très émouvant
mais tu ai dit j'ai pensé évidemment au
beau bébé mais j'ai surtout pensé à mon
chien donc le surtout était important
donc tu es quand même
y'a vraiment il ya déjà des gens
profitent seulement des chiens
bleus mais il me met la question et avec
son conte un feu arrive tu sauves nahla
ta chienne ou arthur
regardez
moi je perds ou tu as
61 % oui 38%